thanks for inviting me here this looks
like a very nice workshop and most of
the things here won't seem necessarily
directly related but it will be a slide
where you will mention kind of how it is
more related and/or actually I think
very related and so you might talk
they're kind of three parts I mean the
title has basically three parts one is
near the Cimber search to is that it's
data dependent hashing using four
nearest neighbor search and part three
will be with it is optimal election okay
and as I mentioned that this work is
joint with Belarus Einstein who is at
MIT all right so let me start from the
beginning
since nobody defined nearest neighbor
search so far let me define it so this
is a data structure question where we
have a point set P in a particular under
say Clinton distance we need to process
it so that we can answer the following
types of queries we given a point query
Q we need to report the point B star
which is closest to the query point Q
okay and we're with shows up in
applications this is a very classical
way to do similarity search you usually
think about points as living in high
dimensional spaces when when these
points represent some kind of images or
some kind of objects in general for
example these are images from a
classical data set called a mist and or
handwritten digits and you can represent
an image as a high dimensional let's say
Hamming vector by you know if you have a
20 by 20 image when this will be a 400
national
Hamming vector and then you can compare
the similarity between three images by
competing the Hamming distance okay this
is how you arrive at the nearest
neighbor search problem in particular
via nearest neighbor search will be
something called K nearest neighbor rule
in machine learning for doing
classification okay and as such this has
many applications in many areas in
computer science and outside I shall not
mention this too much here since this is
your audience so on
kind of more on the serious side I guess
one can consider this problem as under a
number of distances actually so here
this is formulated under Hamming
distance but you can imagine kind of
even more basic question is to think
about this problem under Euclidean
distance but there are also many other
distances like Eddy distance which has
been mentioned a few times today or F
mover distance which is kind of
sometimes used more commonly for images
for example and many others okay and we
would like kind of to design algorithm
generically for such nearest neighbor
search and also this problem is a core
primitive for many problems which show
up in high dimensional geometry a very
classical example is called the spare
problem and will actually give to it a
little bit later in my talk okay but
also clustering in many others
ok so this is a classical problem that
suffers from what is called curse of
dimensionality namely all the solutions
degrade rapidly with dimension D so just
to start twisting the basic case of
dimension equals 2 this is usually
solved by a classical data structure
called Voronoi diagram and then you do
point location here and this will give
you a relatively efficient solution and
one can you know think about a
generalization of that in high
dimensional space and this will
correspond to this basically role which
it will get nice query time but this way
so exponential in D which is obviously
too much space and basically so this is
one option what we can do for hydration
spaces the other option is basically not
do anything be lazy and just at the
query time just scan through the
database ok so this is so this is what
happens for high dimensionals for high
dimension D and because of it kind of
now for a number of years maybe about 20
years researchers have suggested the
problem of approximate nearest neighbor
search we are we have started getting
better results okay so let me define
this precisely so first of all we'll
look at the what is called our near
neighbor think about this is kind of
more fresh hold or decision version kind
of we are we're given a threshold are at
the beginning and now
when we given a query point Q we need to
report any point within distance R okay
so pictorially kind of thing in colors
so it is a key to report anything in
this green ball and it is not okay to
report anything in the red in the red
outskirts and now we introduced
approximation so the approximation will
usually have letter C think about it as
to we'll introduce this bigger ball
basically we'll introduce this gray
analyst and now what we're saying is
that as long as there is some point in
this green ball it is okay to report
either something in the green ball or in
the gray outskirts but not sorry in the
gray analyst but not in the gray in the
red outskirts okay
put differently kind of if you you know
you fishing more like a promise problem
if the data set is such that there is
nothing in these granules when the exact
and approximate versions are exactly the
same problem under this promise and the
practice this is even this approximately
solutions for approximate nearest
neighbor search are often used for
solving the exact nearest neighbor
search as a as a heuristic basically
where as a filtering step you can think
about these algorithms usually reporting
a list of points which is in this gray
ball perhaps some of the points in these
granules and basically you can do post
filtering after such a solution and
throw out all the points that you don't
like for example okay so so this is so
this is the definition of approximate
nearest neighbor other question so far
and so there has been a lot of progress
on it and there are basically two types
of solutions that the community has seen
one is which got a dependence on
dimension which is still exponential but
better than before something like 1 over
epsilon to VD as opposed to enter VD and
the other one which really got enough
linear or maybe polynomial dependence
and dimension and this is really very
Jim that I'll be focusing in on so so
essentially you know all the exception
of the work that I'll be mentioning are
based on the notion of locality
sensitive hashing
and this is a notion introduced by Nick
motwani back in 1998 and it is basically
a random hash function on a geometric
space this is this is what is what is
the concept is and kind of geometrically
you can think a random hash function on
a geometric space as a basic as a random
space partition okay so each part will
correspond to all the points that hash
to the same hash code and get exactly
the same value and now we want this hash
function to be useful somehow so we want
more properties of it and the two
properties that we want are basically
for you consume about four points that
are close basically the points which are
in this great ball and the points that
are far the points that are in the
invalid outskirts any particular we want
but for close pairs this pair these
points are usually in the same budget so
the probability of collision is high and
the four pairs of points that are far is
for example for this point we want this
probability of collision to be small
okay so you know we are still to this
design this cash function but suppose we
managed to design a hash function which
is super efficient let's say this high
is really one this small is let's say
zero so when the solution will be just
to do a hash table to just construct the
hash table so for this data set you'll
just build a hash table hash using this
hash function H I've been during a query
time you just look up the bucket and
these two properties will guarantee that
the points that you find in this budget
are exactly the points that you want to
find now designing such a hash function
you know sounds too good this is too
ambitious I mean we need to lower our
ambition a little bit but not too too
far so it is possible to design hash
functions which will achieve perhaps not
a very big gap but some gap and we will
exploit that gap okay so as long as
there is some gap between these
probabilities we can we can design
efficient - number search and
pictorially kind if you can think about
these probabilities of collision as some
decaying function as a function of the
distance between two points okay
and now you know since this probability
is not so small this means that perhaps
in one hash table we will not find one
the near neighbor but we are looking for
so we need to use several hash tables so
this means that we'll do a few of these
space partitions build a few hash tables
and query all of these hash tables now
the remaining part kind of what remains
is ok how many hash tables do we need
and the number of hash tables is
basically dependent on these two
probabilities of course and if we call
this p1 and if a bigger probability B 2
the smaller probability then the number
the number of hash tables is basically
is dominated by is determined by this
parameter row so basically our query
time will be n to power and this Row is
a function of p1 and p2 ok so my one
described white is like that it is not
too hard to decide but it is always a
constant between 0 and 1 and you should
think about this as the better
approximate the higher approximation we
desire the smaller all be ok so it will
be generally decaying with the
approximation you probably become easier
ok so so this is risky I'm invested to I
won't describe the hash functions in
this particular case but we will see
some construction a little bit later so
so what do we know about other search
algorithms so the original paper showed
a scheme for with Hamming space and it
obtained exponent row which is one of
our scene and I'll just have a running
example of approximation sequels to just
from concreteness so here we get Rho
equals 1/2 so later so this this work
actually applied for Euclidean space as
well by standard reductions and later
with about ranging in 2006 we proved
that you can actually in equilibrium
space you can get better space
partitions and a particular say for
approximation to you can reduce query
time from
10 to 4 fruit of em so then the question
is okay can we do even further and
actually just a few months kind of after
wet paper researches have shown that you
can actually you can prove lower bounds
for less age so these are related to
certain kind of isoparametric
inequalities and you can prove lower
bounds and in particular arms so this
was first in a paper by Matt when an
hour a panic rocky and later in the
O'Donnell borne zoo showed that these
two bounds are actually optimal for
locality-sensitive hashing okay so we
cannot improve using the Lesage okay so
I'll kind of think about that basically
now we don't really have kind of other
techniques or at least at that moment so
basically a less satisfied you know so
this mean now we're really done with the
basic nearest neighbor search all
questions or is there something else so
hold on to that fort and let's do a
detour for a moment so the to deter will
talk about the closest pair problem okay
so let me define it exactly so let me
define the by chromatic version let's
say in the Hamming space so you are
given let's say a blue set and a red set
of points we need to find a pair of
points which are a distance at Massey
are let's say assuming that very
superior distance are okay again there
is or if you want it's a promise problem
there is no pair of points in in between
these two bounds so then we need to
report the points within this answer
okay so and let's say for this slide
think about approximation C as being 1
plus Epsilon so so basically using
locality sensitive hashing or hashing a
particular one can obtain x which are of
the sort of two to minus a constant
times Epsilon okay and that is the
algorithm is simple you'll basically
pre-process a as a data structure and
when you do a query on each point in B
and basically be if you get the number
of hash tables enter power oh you're
you're on time for closest pair will be
and two
one posture and basically replacing
sequel's one perception these are the
runtimes that you'll get okay so
recently there has been so this was the
case kind of for a number of years and
as a recently there has been more
progress on this problem but we started
utilizing mattress implication to get
faster algorithms so in particular in
work of Ullman and Williams we showed
that you can solve exact closest pair so
you know shrink of Epsilon's being 0 as
long as dimension is basically
proportional to log n so you can get you
know truly sub-quadratic time as long as
dimension is basically log n times a
constant again there is a relation
between this constant is concerned okay
in another line of work initiated by
greg valiant and then recently improved
by carpark ASCII and kohonen they showed
that they considered the average case
for this problem and it's also called
light bulb problem and if it's been
studied before but here they showed that
for this average case you can get again
essentially a truly sub-quadratic time
for dimension sufficiently large and for
epsilon fixes are constantly saying let
me see exactly what is the average case
since we need it later
so think about this as your points are
fully random in the dimensional space
and then you'll Sapir you you plant a
pair of points a distance basically G by
1/2 divided by C all right so your
random two random points will be a
distance D by 2 roughly and you plant a
pair which is a distance C less okay so
this is the kind of average case so this
is the run times but it is possible to
get again much better than this time and
so Greg comes off what about how if if
we can extend this to the worst case and
basically the best bound that Greg
valonqar was to 2 minus theta root
epsilon so this is I mean this is a
better dependence on Epsilon
but again as epsilon goes to zero this
goes to quadratic time but basically the
conclusion of you know to remember kind
of evidence is that one can get much
more efficient algorithms for closest
pair as long as dimension let's say is
order log N or if you consider the
average case and closest pair and if
it's a classical problem many other
people mention the connection to self
and this is not the point of this talk
but I thought it'd be nice to mention
these connections okay
so so okay so this was ready to going
back to nearest neighbor search so
subject in unison research so it turns
out that we can go beyond local
sensitive hashing and get better
algorithms for nearest neighbor search
okay so let me tell you first how the
results look like and then I'll tell you
how one gets around the local assistive
hashing lower bounds so so this is the
type this is what has been proven for
all the sage say for Hamming space
exponent is Row one over C so in joint
work with water intake linguae and in
the residence time in 2014 we showed
that you can get throw which is a little
bit less than half minus epsilon for
approximation to okay so exact exponent
is a little bit more complicated to
write down also in part because
basically in this work with a letter 16
we showed that you can get Rho which is
equal to 1 over 2 C minus 1 or to be
specific for approximation to this goes
to exponent which is an to effort
exactly the same improvement is possible
for Euclidean space as well so one gets
from let's say exponent 1/4 to exponent
one over seven if a larger C this is
basically a quadratic time improvement
and basically I'll be focusing on the
celebration and I'm pretty much will be
showing this algorithm in this talk
other questions so far
okay so the question should be how do we
get around the lower bound for Less age
and and the real kind of you know the
idea was in the title well the idea is
to use data dependent hashing so what is
data dependent hashing so think about
this we are still using a random hash
function to partition the space except
that that hash function is chosen after
we have seen the data set okay so it can
adapt to the actual data set that we see
now so if this is all I've told you kind
of if this is a goal given a data set
now you have to design a random hash
function that partitioned space well for
nearest neighbor search what should be
the hash function says born a diagram
all right this is the best this is the
best space partition for a given data
set right now something is wrong because
we're back to we're not boring a diagram
and the problem is that computing this
hash function is is inefficient where it
takes a lot of time linear with data set
so what we really want we want a hash
function which depends depends on the
data set has nicer properties but it's
also efficiently computable so we rule
out were on a diagram okay so this will
be big-oh okay so and this is what we'll
see later in the talk now before kind of
going for her you know since there are
many people kind of more complexity side
let me kind of tell you why the lower
bound for Lesage does not exactly
transfer to a lower bound for nearest
neighbor search okay so the Alice's
lower bounds kind for both cases for
Hamming and fake lydian proceed by
proving lower Bonnie's Hamming space and
it were basically for analytic as a
pragmatic inequalities pretty much and
the first one was shown by Matt one in
our panic roughly two thousand six six
and the proof kind of goes in the
following way you kind of assume any
distribution H Big H over your hash
functions into a discrete universe and
then you're designing kind of the hard
instance as saying that let's consider
for pains for pair of points as being PQ
completely random in which case you're a
distance D by two
roughly the clothes pair is PQ which are
random but conditioned to be a distance
D by 2 divided by C right so C factor
factor C closer and forgive her
distribution for any distribution age of
hash functions we show that Rho has to
be essentially at least half bison okay
so then came okay from a dimension but
note that this is basically corresponds
allows to the average case considering
the closest pair problem so men comes
Donald one to five years later and they
say like well this is not the best the
best setting of parameters for proving a
lower bound we said but well if we take
actually the far pair to be correlated
as well to be correlated to be a
distance Delta times D for Delta think
about is very small close pair is by
factor C smaller in that case you can
prove Rho which is essentially Titleist
H bound one over C okay so now the
question is okay you know can these type
of lower bound this kind of hard
distribution can it be generalized to
nearest neighbor search can it lead to a
nearest neighbor search lower bound and
the answer is basically no and here is
the reason so you pick a random Q let's
say so with our points so when you say
that well I'll generate a lot of our
points that you know should be bad for
the sage now all these four points are
correlated with our point Q right we are
all within in a small bowl of radius
basically some epsilon D okay and if
you're if you can process this situation
then you you can detect the structure
you can see what your data set has
additional structure and maybe you can
exploit it and this is exactly what the
audience although we will be able to
exploit this kind of structure and
basically avoid these kind of lower
bounds okay so let me go into the actual
construction so actual algorithm now so
there are two components right so coming
back kind of to the average case
description so component number one
shows that if your point set is
essentially average case point set which
I'll define off
the next slide then you can actually
design better data independent space
partitions okay so I think about this
easier data has more structure than you
can do even better space partitions okay
so this is part one part two says that
any worst-case data set can be reduced
to business data structure and this is
the part that will be data dependent
this is where we look at the interns
start doing surgery and from that
perspective you can think about this
reduction as you know a very weak
regularity lemma for a set of points
right regular dilemmas are basically the
statements so the sort of you can take
any worst-case object do certain kind of
surgery on it and reduce to average case
situation okay so this is these are veto
components so let me start with I mean
we'll spend most of the time soon on the
second component so the first component
is you know showing that average case
has nice and fracture visas this is this
was the contribution of the first paper
and here is here's how it looks looks
like so think about I mean so the
average case will be now in the million
space I mean it doesn't really matter if
it is a Hamming space or a clean space
it turns out that if you do all bridges
in Euclidean space they also imply
algorithms in Hamming space and the
actual algorithm the actual reduction is
much more naturally fought in Euclidean
spaces of posting Hamming space so you
clean space now so think about the data
set is essentially being round on points
at on a sphere which basically means
that all the vectors are pretty much
perpendicular to each other in high
dimensional geometry random vectors are
usually perpendicular to each other and
also we want that two random points are
roughly distance here so this is the far
distance right we're saying that if we
take the query point let say and any
random point on this year this point is
roughly at the limit of the far distance
okay so pictorially we have this fear we
pick two random points that you know
will be perpendicular vectors there are
distance here which basically means that
you know they are random on a sphere of
a certain radius
reduces CR by root 2 so dilemma proven
that prepare is that for this case we
can get fro which is better okay this is
this improved robot where we are getting
okay and the construction is basically
something we call kept carving and it's
related to some some methods introduced
in 90s by Karim a 20 and Sudan in here
and also used in the other paper with
filtering dick in 2006 forgetting
forgetting better partitions free clean
space so here this is a partition of of
the surface of the sphere and the way it
works is the following so you basically
pick a distance from the center to the
hyperplane then you basically cut out
the the cap of the sphere and you
proceed so by picking these random caps
until we have covered the entire sphere
now these caps intersect so you take
precedence basically the first cups the
first cap wins reporting basically from
the picture and I won't describe why
this obtains better exponent that the
generally clean space but it seems to
have to do something with the curvature
of this face basically in some sense the
distance from this here is is bigger
than the distance the direct distance
between two points okay so this is this
is a the space partition and now we'll
go into the reduction actually other
questions about that so far
this is one hash function the random
choices the directions of these caps and
you know you to you you can compute
probability p1 of collision of close
points probability P 2 of collision of
four points basically points which are
in this configuration and then Rho is a
function of p1 in p2 and this is the
formula to get okay so so this is the
average so now the statement is that you
can reduce any worst-case point set to
this Everage case points okay now how
does it as duction go so we'll have a
running example here of point set so
think about this as we have we start
with some point set which lies in a ball
of larger radius and has beta hats no
structure and say let's let's say radius
is by you know hundred times more than
it should be
hundreds are so the basic idea would be
to iteratively to do certain kind of
surgery but we'll see in a second and
that is to reduce the radius of a
minimum closing ball okay will reduce
this until we reduce until we get two
V's radius roughly CR by Row two and
then it will basically be easy to seal
off video so the main step of a kind of
of these surgery I guess is indentifying
dense clusters okay so this is kind of
similar to the lower bound where say
like there is a tight ball which
contains a lot of points and it is much
smaller than the point set this is what
we'll be doing basically we'll find a
dense cluster the dense cluster means
something that has smaller radius who
has progress on the radio's but still
contains a large fraction of points will
parameterize these a little bit later
but this is just pictorial at the moment
will extract these dense clusters we
recurse on them on the dense clusters
but then we also have to deal with these
remaining point set which is basically
no dense cluster points so what we'll do
here actually we'll just apply
kept carving as these on this PowerPoint
set here so it means that we will draw a
few tabs will partition the points a
little bit on on on the surface of this
year these partitions the points and a
few more parts and we'll recurse on all
these parts
basically we recurse both on dense
clusters and on each of these caps so
this means that for example here we
might find new dense clusters when we
should records and so forth so the
general structure so this is think about
this as kind of this algorithm will
replace one hash table okay and in
particular with let's hold on the
thought but let me explain why can we
apply kept carving on the rest okay why
why is it ok to apply kept carving on
this big sparse point set okay in some
sense this is exactly the reason why we
extracted the dense clusters okay so the
way we extracted the dense clusters will
ensure that the remaining point set
basically looks like this average-case
point set in a much bigger bowl which
essentially means that the average point
in the average Interpol in distance
there are still roughly perpendicular to
each other but the distance is even
larger than when we hoped for this is
like solving the nearest neighbor search
for much larger approximation which is
which means that is just a simpler
problem okay so cup carving works even
better than as if then for approximation
see okay the main point being here is
that the remaining this parse kind of
remaining point set looks essentially
like a random or average case data set
okay so the the hash function again kind
of for the hash function is basically
can be described by a three this is a
hash table and you know it looks the
following you know your entire point set
will correspond to the root its it is
gray we identified some dense clusters
you extract them this will correspond to
heading two children one corresponds to
the dense clusters one corresponding to
the node s cluster set now this dense
cluster sets are partitioned further
down we've kept carving basically in a
few caps this means that we partition
the points at server and then perhaps
you records on all these colored parts
you find more discuss ters you extract
them you wreckers so this is the high
level perspective and novel I'll
describe a little bit more in detail how
we find these dense clusters and all the
so so dense clusters okay so so the
current dataset has radius R right so a
dense cluster will be a dense cluster
that contains n - 1 minus Delta point so
that will be a parameter but we'll fix
later ok and when the following property
so the dense we want we essentially do
we extract points that violate directly
what it means to be average case
basically pischedda random
basically this means that a dense
cluster means that we find a point on
the surface of this year such that there
are many points which are a little bit
less than being perpendicular from us so
all the points all the points that are
basically here perpendicular here will
be a distance roughly root 2 times the
radius so we're saying that either is a
ball of radius root 2 minus epsilon for
a small epsilon that contains many
points where many points means n 2 minus
1 minus epsilon we will extract all the
points on the surface of the sphere
this would be our dense cluster ok now
this ball this red ball has a radius
much larger than what we started with
this red ball has radius which is
roughly root 2 times R as opposed to we
are trying to reduce the radius of the
ball well the cool part is that what we
really care is that the surface of this
year and the surface surface here can be
inscribed basically the surface of this
year intersection of this red red ball
can be inscribed in this purple ball
which has radius which has smaller
radius it has radius something like 1
minus Omega epsilon squared R so this
blue ball will be our dense cluster this
is the ball that has progress on the on
the radius
now after we remove your cluster
basically we just look for all the
points that contain very many points
within this red ball kind of radius like
roughly root 2 minus epsilon times R we
inscribe in the smaller ball we extract
them as much as we can until we find
normal balls this means that after we
have done this for any point on the
surface there are at most n - 1 - data
points within distance root 2 minus
Epsilon
so you can think of I mean this is I
mean this is some kind of progress
towards where we want to be in a minute
but all the points are essentially
perpendicular orthogonal to each other
except for certain kind of impurity
which has magnitude n - 1 and s Delta so
in several points essentially orthogonal
now we will be applying for wheels after
we moved all clusters and the remaining
points that we're applying the cap
carbon with some parameters P 1 P 2 P 1
is the probability of collision of close
points and P 2 is probability of
collision of four points so in some
sense what we need to look at is the
empirical number of points that remain
in in a particular chunk in a particular
bucket corresponding to the query let's
say so the empirical number of four
points will be n times P - and this
comes from the cap carving it says for
all the points that are essentially
orthogonal the probability of collision
is Peto
now this doesn't hold for probably 4
points which are visiting impurity
because they must can be much closer and
then we kept carving doesn't apply to
them but you know they're at most n - 1
- dot on it so this is in some sense the
impurity of this so as long as basically
this term is much larger miss 1 the
impurity is a small term basically it
doesn't matter as much
yes sir cluster a set of points that are
essentially around them and therefore
they could do carving so inside the
dense clusters we have no structure
right right so in a sense think about
this this impurity is good at this level
but then we partition a little bit of
cap carving this means that the number
of points gets much closer to this bound
so now something that wasn't dense
faster before suddenly begins to be a
dense cluster basically this is I mean
so there is some kind of impurity of a
point set and it is just a little bit
less than polynomial then sorry been
linear in n okay so when you start
partitioning a point set at some moment
as you go through probably the trivia
tree each node of the tree will kind of
contain a part of a data set and it
shrinks now that impurity starts to be
proportional or kind of roughly the same
magnitude as a now of the data set size
there so then this impurity begins to
matter so this is why in some sense
thing about this rate the recursion will
start looking at the impurity
I mean if your points where to be
completely perpendicular like all of
them then yes we can just look up
carving and so there but there is this
impurity to do so in a sense this is
kind of you know it is not a pure
reduction right I mean it internalizes
the steps of kind of faster algorithm
for average case and the reduction to
average case okay so there are a few
pound of you know ones there are
parameters it's kind of good to
understand what is the trade-off of
these parameters why can't we push over
epsilon or Delta - you know zero or one
so let's look at epsilon so the epsilon
is trade-off between two things one is
the smaller radius how much progress we
make on the radius we want discipline to
be not too small
in the upper part is the notion of
essentially orthogonal but if we make
epsilon to be too large then this means
whether further and far away from
basically being nearly orthogonal and
when things begin to degrade right we
are not exactly as promised orthogonal
okay so this is absurd now Delta is a
trade-off between well basically this
formula but you know which one's Delta
to be as high as possible all right and
the other one we'll see on the next
slide
all right so just to recap how this
looks like so we have a tree and
basically during the query what happens
is that we'll recurse will will recur
cinahl clusters and in one bucket in cap
carbon so when you have a query so
pictorially when you have a query you
don't really know over in your neighbor
is one of the dense clusters or it is in
the remaining part so you have to go in
all of them now once you are in cap
carving part now this is these functions
as a real standard hash function so you
just go into one part so there is a
certain amount of branching happening
which depends on the number of these
dense clusters particularly look in more
than one leaf so how much branching
happens so the claim is that the number
of the amount of branching basically the
number of leaves who look at is
essentially n to power Delta plus 1 to
some power which depends on epsilon and
here is the proof so each time you
branch it means that there are at most n
to power Delta clusters this was the
reason why we wanted custer's to be
relatively heavy so with there are not
too many plus 1 from this parse part and
the good part is that each time we
branch the cluster reduces radius by at
least an epsilon squared so since there
are we started with radius which is like
100 CR they are basically only 100 by
epsilon squared steps that you can do of
this branching and hence reclaim so
basically this is the upper part of the
trainer this is why we don't want to
make Delta to be too large
okay how much more time do I have 12 -
okay no so we're essentially done so
progress happens in two ways here okay
so one is with the clusters when we
remove the clusters and recursion
clusters the clusters reduce the radius
whereas the kept carving you know kind
of when we go into this side the
progress that happens is that these this
hash function basically partitioned the
points and basically each part reduces a
lot the number of points in the part so
you know at the end of the day you prove
that these three succeeds in finding the
closest pair with probability and to
essentially a row - smaller fun where
this row is 1 over 2 T Square minus 1
okay so we have to repeat as many times
- to get a constant probability of
finding your near neighbor so yeah so
one I guess one question that pops up is
you know how do we do these dense
cluster finding efficiently so this is
pretty processing you know you might or
might not care about your processing in
case you do you can do it first ok and
here is the reason so step number one is
that you can actually you know receptor
1 is that you can reduce the time to
find dense clusters to quadratic time so
originally it is not clear how to do it
even in polynomial time because you have
to remove such clusters for any point on
the on the surface of this year so it
turns out that with some loss of
parameters it is enough to consider
centers that are data set points so you
can just consider this for each data set
point so that's step one step two is
that you can actually reduce it to
nearly linear time from here mostly
because you can do down sampling your
clusters are heavy objects we contain a
lot of points so if you don't sample the
big structure you can still see it in
case you extracted this intuition
all right so I'm essentially out of time
so there are many more details actually
there is a lot of things that have been
swept under the carpet in particular
that you have to work with empirical
estimates of people just because of all
the data dependency which begins to be
delicate because you have to condition
on certain events in particular in
particular you have to know this I guess
go straight here you'll have to do LSH
analysis of basically collision of
points for three points right which is
kind of different from what has been
happening before so this is part one
part two is that in dense clusters some
of you notice that both that purple ball
is not centered it's it's surface does
not correspond to the surface of
originals here which means that some
points move inside and this begins to be
trouble so then you have to do kept
carving works for points on this sphere
surface only so then you have to do more
partitioning of the ball into thin
shells and the course on the shells mass
of any just saying that there are more
details okay and this is actually
finishes in my talk so let me just
conclude so the main and if message is
that you can do you can go beyond LSH
bounds and get better interesting
research is that data dependent hashing
in particular what I have shown you is a
reduction from worst case to average
case point set and this implies a
nearest neighbor search with query time
which is an to power rule for this row
for this improve drop for the clean air
space so going forward kind of you know
what are the natural questions to be
asked one is can we get even better
bounds here okay so there are you know
good news and bad news the good news is
that for dimension which is proportional
to log n you can get better you can get
Rho which is better than this one
okay so this is a upcoming paper in soda
by a Thai slide humming so this is I
mean in some sense I want to contrast it
with the situation for closest pair
where basically the paper by almond and
Williams showed that if your dimension
is proportional to again you can get
truly sub-quadratic time so for
dimension which is bigger than Logan
let's say for dimension bigger than log
n to power 1 plus Delta in joint work we
are at 16 we prove that this Row is
optimal for data dependent hashing okay
now you have to formalize what it means
to be optimal in this situation because
you have to rule out Verona diagram and
the way we formalize it we restrict the
description complex to the hash function
to be sublinear
basically can't remember all the points
ok so even if you do vote on a diagram
on the route endpoints this is the best
bound that you can get ok another very
good question that we fought for a bit
was whether you can do that reduction
and apply these kind of reductions for
other settings where you have better
algorithms for average case but not for
worst case so this reduction as the
moment works for nearest neighbor search
only another kind of a novel perspective
another question is kind of more an
algorithmic side is to confess it with
nearest neighbor search for an affinity
in particular back in 1998 patron dick
shot that you can for L infinity metric
you can get approximation which is log
log D with polynomial space and sub
linear query time and the nice part with
the deterministic decision tree ok so
you know there is natural question you
know can we get better approximation
turns out that at least for this model
basically for with decision trees even
for randomized once we are matching
lower bounds of order log log D and so
cliff mentioned previous talk that every
other talk mentions me hyper traffic
with name so this is repeating a little
bit this will actually also mention kind
of
is work so this is joint work with Doran
crater on the high patrasche code and
later on kind of extension to the
randomized case was by medical problems
and arena panagra so the cool part okay
kind of connecting back to what we're
talking about is that this algorithm can
now be photos data dependent hashing so
in some sense it pulls this nearest
neighbor search for different metrics
under the same umbrella and it leads to
the question of can we now use say data
dependent hashing or this kind of
techniques for designing nearest
neighbor search under any norm for
example some of the you know coulombs
web I'll be happy to think about it
matrix norms say spectral norm or FM
over distance okay so I'm done here but
I'll just kind of you know my
conclusions you know from this work and
from other from other works that we have
been working on is that my perspective
on our BOTS is that this is an
opportunity to discover new algorithmic
techniques and they'll end here thank
you
what open is the question Pope where
this works when you're doing the the
linear you know the end of the 1 plus
Delta like time or whatever for to build
your hash table given the set right is
there anything that you can do in terms
of updates compared to like LSH it my
great great question so basically can we
make this data structure dynamic great
question right it is not obvious why it
should be possible because if your hash
function see each of spaced partitions
depend on the data set as you change the
data set your contractions may become
completely unusable so it turns out that
you can use essentially standard
dynamization techniques to make this
dynamic kind of nothing facing going on
kind of you know you'll do visual
techniques it can make it can be made
dynamic like not even amortized kind of
in doses
Oh questions sorry I don't seem to have
a lot of this structure like higher
ceilings similar results and so use it
to get a faster version great question I
mean you Joe and me we're trying to
think about this and if I was trying to
write some experiments actually soon
it's a great question is we don't know
yet the answer but it's the right
question to ask